like why do you guys feel like we as
women should be like okay it's fine you
guys you should read the Quran hello
come together again with one woman
charity who I trust Abdullah who want
the 100 donation policy we are now
raising funds to build houses for those
who have been homeless due to natural
disasters in Afghanistan Syria and
Pakistan please donate whatever you can
may Allah build you guys at home for
helping and enabling them to have a
house so guys we're going to be reacting
to a video from fresh and fit or should
I call it haram and fit why
because things that they're saying on
that program which is very very absurd
because they are misrepresenting Islam
as if Islam says or allows these things
which is absolutely wrong now Seiko came
to Islam and you take him to Islam may
Allah preserve them and Myron is a born
Muslim himself but he himself says some
very outrageous stuff and I'm being just
here now is there a lot of facts my one
speaks yes he does I've bought his book
called um I think it's called why women
deserve less or something along those
lines okay
just to see what he said now there is a
lot of facts in there and there's some
extreme things that he says we follow
Islam we don't follow the red pill or
the feminism both man-made women made
rules let's watch this video and let's
see what they are saying on the show and
how it is absolutely false and a big fat
lie in slander against what Allah sent
in his guitar which is the Quran let's
watch it for ourselves
well I mean I would think I don't know
if I'm speaking for the majority here or
not but my man is my man like I don't
care if you thought that you wanted to
do things with multiple women like then
we're not meant to be together I feel
okay do you think that men actually
really want to be monogamous one girl
some do yes no they don't the answer is
no you can't speak on behalf I can I can
tell you maybe the majority if I lined
up 100 dudes and I told them listen you
can have four girls or one girl and I
promise you that girl won't get mad
she'll let you have sex with other girls
she won't get mad they'll take the four
girls most guys are monogamous because
of women like you they tell them if you
I'm leaving I'm leaving that's why
most guys have monogamous because most
girls like you too right now can't take
the truth and also just out to that
point as well that's what they like
you're gonna leave so it's like you know
what I'll tell you what she wants to
hear so I can stay in in a good Grace
but on the side I'm gonna hit Betty at
four in the morning
what acceptable like why do you guys
feel like we as women should be like
okay it's fine you guys you should read
the Quran
so guys you saw that for yourself yeah
this notion this perception this thing
that they are propagating which that a
man can commit dinner a man can have as
many you know sleep around do whatever
he likes but if it's a woman
now there's two angles to this which we
need to understand number one in Islam
in the Sharia
categorically clear Allah says in the
Quran For Those who commit sex outside
of marriage if they are both unmarried
there is the punishment of a hundred
lashes for them having sex outside of
marriage if they are married there is a
capital punishment clear-cut capital
punishment because we know how the
breakdown of the family unit has an
impact on the whole society as a whole
so therefore the capital punishment is
the same for a man and woman it doesn't
say just for a man but not from uh or
just for a woman but not for a man no in
the hair of the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him was he saw something it was
a dream something it wasn't a dream that
he saw a group of people in an oven yes
and they were burning
and who were these these were men and
women not women who committed adultery
yes sex outside of marriage both men and
women Islam does not differentiate when
it comes to the act of Haram Zina if
it's done by a man or a woman now if
we're seeing the consequences socially
is different of course it is different
sadly it should be like that study is
different because if a woman for example
has intimacy with more than one man that
will have an impact on the man that
choose to marry her that's the reality
that's that is a sad reality that we
live in doubt that how men are created
when they make this decision they don't
give a damn about her career she's a
millionaire they don't give a damn I
even done a social experiment about this
a man doesn't give a damn and you've
slept with
around the block of 10 20 men no man
wants to marry you simple as that but
for a man sadly the other way is true
however this does not give a Muslim man
or anyone for that matter to say yeah
because there's no social implications
Etc no this is false so I want to make a
category clear to my run
I'm going to sneak on said anything like
that yeah okay and they're putting these
buzzers there like Allah Etc it's not a
joke it's not funny guys okay there's a
lot of Truth you guys speak I understand
however this propagation that you're
propagating of yeah in Islam is okay no
it is not it is not however can a man
have four wives yes he can and he's not
criminalized for that he's not guilty
for that that is in his body on the Jeep
so he is created like 100 a man has can
have more than one wife two three four
wives and why this is sent down to
protect the woman this is sitting down
so a man who has this inclination this
propensity to do these things of having
more than one woman in his life
he does it in the right way he doesn't
have Mistresses side chicks and
girlfriends he can use an abuse like the
toilet you know a toilet when you feel
like you need to go use the toilet and
relieve yourself and you find the toilet
and you just whoa go in I mean number
one number two woof yeah stink up the
whole place yeah so the same with a man
he has this propensities and his
intonations so he's using this woman by
you know penetrating her you know
ejaculating inside her like she's a
toilet Islam says no if you are going to
do it you are going to do it in an
honorable Way by honoring the second
wife number one speaking to a father
number two get into Noah in a Halal way
not let me test drive if I don't like it
then you can go no not using abuser then
you marry her then you do a wedding then
you give her a dowry which you can
choose money Gold Card whatever she
wants it's totally up to Islam gives it
the right to us or whatever she likes
that is her security and announce the
marriage is not hidden it is announced
and then you are the protector and the
provider for the second life as well and
you do not favor one over the other
because the prophet Muhammad peace upon
him said the man who favors one wife
over the other will come under their
judgment his body leaning on one side it
is not a joke it's a serious matter So
for anybody in fresh and fit it was
propagating that Islam allows a man to
go sleep around this is a big fat lie
and it's a slander one of the biggest
things in Islam equate to Shir is what
for you to say a statement about Allah
that Allah didn't say for himself yes
you do not see it and we know it from
the narration of the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him I think it's from
banish Israel that there was a man who
saw his brother sinning over and over
again and one day he would always scold
his brother don't stop sinning stop
sinning and this brother of his himself
was very righteous so he would keep
warning him and one day he came to him
and said you are going to go Hellfire
you're never going to go Jannah they
both die and they both come to the
presence of God Almighty and Allah says
to the man did you tell him that he's
going Hellfire yes he says indeed you're
going now fire because you have said a
statement about me without no knowledge
you're going Hellfire and that man who
he he said to his brother is going on
fire went to Paradise why because you
cannot utter a statement on behalf of
God that God Almighty hasn't said so
Myron and sneak out whoever your
brothers are with all due respect please
do not say this statement you can say a
man in Islam has a right to marry one
two three four wives
true hack but to say that he can go
sleep around is false that man will get
the capital punishment just as a woman
would
till next time